so what I want to do here is make a
video answering the question exactly how
powerful is apocalypse and relation to
other characters from around the Marvel
Universe and what I'm hoping is that at
the end of all this you'll have had a
little fun but also learn a little bit
more about my favorite villain and what
he's capable of
so as beginning to this what we're going
to do is we're going to divide this
video into three sections focusing on
the strength of apocalypse followed by
his ability to battle teams and finally
we're going to ask the question can he
defeat Thanos so the first part of our
discussion on the team element of
Apocalypse that I want to focus on comes
during his introduction and etch factor
under Walter and Louise Simonson as a
syriza saw the original five x-men of
Phoenix Cyclops Iceman beast and Angel
forming their own branch off team
apocalypse debuted in issue number six
but didn't actually battle the team
until issue number 24 as part of an
ongoing story arc stretching between the
pages of x-factor New Mutants
power-packed forward daredevil and
uncanny x-men the mutant Massacre and
subsequent follow mutants story arcs
dealt with a combination of the Morlocks
being massacred in the sewers of New
York the mutant Registration Act and
apocalypse brainwashing Warren
Worthington into becoming his horseman
death in addition to gathering plague
autumn Wolfson and Abraham Kiros to
operate its famine pestilence and war
respectively were the forces of
apocalypse engaging in battle against
the x-men as in most cases he sent the
horsemen against them to do his bidding
now initially the horsemen were
successful in capturing the x-men but
once they were on board apocalypse his
ship and managed to get free he faced
off against them by himself because
apocalypse has the power to alter the
molecular structure of his body and use
any physical superhuman power the x-men
were completely outmatched and even
after archangel had turned against
apocalypse there was really nothing they
could do here but we treat and figure
out how to defeat him some other way now
this particular instance is only for
x-men and while they were fighting
apocalypse
they were also dealing with a multitude
of other things including Warren
Worthington becoming a villain and
trying to keep apocalypse as celestial
ship from crashing in a New York City
something they were unsuccessful in
doing and so the question I propose is
this what would it look like if
apocalypse took on a full contingent of
the x-men with no distractions
well the answer to this question comes
with x-factor issue number 68 titled
bitter sacrifices written by Jim Lee and
Chris Claremont and centering on the
efforts of apocalypse in kidnapping
Nathan summers and infecting him with a
techno-organic virus apocalypse had
taken refuge on the blue area of the
moon and formed a group called the
writers of the storm composed of various
mutants and Inhumans when the story saw
Black Bolt Cyclops and the Inhumans and
x-men banding together in an effort to
save the captured in humans and mutants
during the battle apocalypse fought both
Cyclops and Black Bolt while
simultaneously withstanding attacks from
both heroes now what's particular about
this is Black Bolt and that his voice is
powerful enough to wipe out entire
planets the fact that apocalypse is able
to withstand such an attack is a
testament to how powerfully truly is
regarding his ability to withstand
attacks from his opponents what was also
revealed to us is that apocalypse as
power is so vast that in order to ensure
his survival he has to transfer his
energy from one house to another due to
the fact that his power quite literally
burns out the body of the person he's
inhabited now having said that I want to
shift our focus to the Incredible Hulk
during Peter David's run which has
become the stuff of legend in issue
number 456 apocalypse had
single-handedly subdued the Hulk and
held him against his will now this
moment is a short one and there's not
much here to delve into regarding our
discussion but there's also one caveat
that we have to talk about this
particular story titled apocalypse
remakes the Hulk meet war comes out of
the onslaught saga when the minds of
Charles Xavier and Magneto had merged
into a singular being who looked to
dominate the world near the conclusion
of the story Jean Grey had separated the
Hulk and banner personas from one
another meaning that within the context
of this story Hulk has a finite amount
of strength and does not get stronger as
he gets angrier while the strength is
still massive compared to most everyone
else the fact remains that this
modification to his character actually
skews things a bit and so to balance the
scales what I want to do is bring Thor
into the picture
since he's also a character with
incredible strength and can also help to
provide a more comprehensive discussion
so apocalypse is fight against Thor
actually takes place at uncanny Avengers
issue number 6 from 2013 coming it's
fallout from The Avengers vs. x-men
storyline and the return of the Phoenix
force one of the subplots of the story
was that while the Avengers working
silly hailed as heroes the x-men were
shunned by society despite having saved
the world on several occasions to this
end under Brick Remender Marvel released
uncanny Avengers to operate as a
combination of Avengers and x-men
working under the avengers banner
covering the early days of Odin's son's
life as Thor the story actually saw
apocalypse making his appearance and
completely pummeling Odin's son jumping
back to Scandinavian 1013 ad the events
unfolded alongside Thor the God of
Thunder with issue number three
illustrating that Odin's son was unable
to lift me all near for reasons that
weren't fully explained but regarding
this story the conflict between
apocalypse and Thor is rooted in the
fact that apocalypse has traveled to the
past with the aid of Kane the Conqueror
because still will present a challenge
to apocalypses schemes later in the
future to this end without Mjolnir
the battle between Odin Sun and
apocalypse is pretty short and that Thor
is using yarn broom but is incapable of
inflicting enough damage against
apocalypse to send him running instead
wenona son comes to the realization that
he's outclassed he retreats back to
Asgard seeking the wisdom of Odin never
odin rejects the requests of for under
the guise that his actions will lead to
ruin in the future loki offers odin son
that help he seeks in the form of an
enchantment that allows the axe to
pierce a celestial armor because
apocalypse use a celestial technology
when Thor returns to battle apocalypse
for a second time he's able to pierce
his armor and win him severely enough
that apocalypse is forced to retreat now
something I want to point out here is
that by himself for was incapable of
defeating apocalypse despite his vast
strength and it's Guardian physiology it
wasn't until he enchanted his axe that
he actually became a credible threat and
so getting into the final part of our
discussion the question of whether or
not apocalypse can defeat Thanos is
actually not a question we can answer
directly since the two have never
battled one another instead we're going
to have to answer this question in a
roundabout way by referencing what was
discussed with apocalypse so far along
with what Thanos has demonstrated within
his own comics so regarding Thanos and
truth he has some big advantages over
apocalypse for one Thanos has spent a
majority of his life traversing the
spaceways and as seen in done things
apocalypse never has for example during
a search for the Infinity stones he met
and overcame the elders of the universe
each of whom represented the last
remaining member of their race while
wouldn't say that all of them are
incredibly powerful something to take
note of is if Thanos effectively duped
them all instead of finding them in a
battle which goes towards his level of
intelligence in dealing with individuals
who have existed for billions of years
something else to note here is that
during the Thanos 12 issue miniseries
from 2003 and the first six issues he
faced off against Galactus who intended
to gather the Infinity stones to cure
his hunger now where the story took a
turn and saw the Galactus was being
manipulated by a being from another
reality
the fact remains that Thanos went
toe-to-toe against one of the most
powerful entities in the Marvel Universe
without using an infinity gauntlet or
enchantment of any kind
however apocalypse also has full access
to the technological spectrum of the
Celestials a race of beings whose powers
equal to if not a little greater than
Galactus furthermore apocalypse can
alter the molecular structure of his
body and potentially make it so dense
the Thanos can't damage him but in the
end we're talking about a situation with
a being who has entered the realm of
death and returned battled a cosmic
entity to a standstill and it's hand
control of the universe going
head-to-head against a villain who is
routinely struggle to conquer the earth
and so as much as I love apocalypse and
truth I have to give this one to Thanos
simply because the mad Titan has seen
and done too much and it's far too
powerful for any attack that apocalypse
can throw at him with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and let me know down in the comments
section what do you think do you think
that apocalypse can be pharaohs or do
you think that Thanos will always beat
apocalypse regardless of the
circumstance and I will catch you guys
on it peace